so many people and i'm going to include
myself
who uh feel like oh my god i don't want
to make a mistake
i want to be an ally i want to
move the piece forward i want to
be the solution and not part of the
problem
but i'm terrified of making a mistake
and that leads to
i think a paralysis that is not helping
can you speak to that a little bit
yeah you know and i i like kind of using
the term you know
uh co-conspirators or accomplices uh
rather than allies you know
but those folks are the people who've
made mistakes
uh and who've heard the feedback
learned and kept going right um that
that paralysis is
it's you know it's really really i think
actually
really selfish um and and incredibly
unhelpful
you will so the question isn't what do i
do if i say the wrong thing
it's what when i do this or say the
wrong thing
what's the best way for me to respond in
that moment you know we're all going to
mess up and it's not just around race
men are going to say the wrong thing to
women we're going to misgender people
we're all
you know we are all going to do and say
the wrong thing and cause someone harm
so often in a way that we're absolutely
not meaning to and that's so often what
people say well that wasn't my intention
like i didn't mean that i didn't that
wasn't my intention
but if but it's something that you do or
say harm someone
uh and and they let you know that what
you need to be able to do is listen to
them and hear them
and understand how you can do better the
next time you know if
and if we just let that paralysis uh you
know take over and we just don't say
anything
uh you know that's that's that's part of
the large systemic problem we have